une nouvelle version du projet gare
bécane après plusieurs mois de blocage
les élus de l'agglomération et la vie de
la verrière sont finalement parvenus à
un accord pour relancer le projet
principale nouveauté la construction de
1000 logements contre 1800 initialement
quand vous avez un trop gros projets de
densification ça des effets bien sûr sur
les autres communes dont il ya eu des
échanges jusqu'à modifier faire évoluer
le projet donc s'est-il 4 sur soi c'est
nos objectifs qu'on a gardé qu'on a
qu'on
on le définit autrement mais sont les
mêmes objectifs
parce que c'est important d'avoir on a
été élu sur un programme on n'a pas été
aidé sur un autre programme adopté en
conseil communautaire les nouvelles
orientations du projet ont suscité de
vives discussions entre les élus et je
rappelle que le seul axe structurant
route de la zac des bécanes ce sera la
départementale 13 ans cinq des six
conseillers communautaires de maurepas
se sont abstenus pour cette délibération
inquiets notamment des répercussions
d'un tel projet pour leur ville
je m'inquiète en tant que maire de
maurepas sur les impacts qu'auront ces
aménagements sur la ville dans le futur
et comment les nouveaux habitants
vont-ils circuler dans cette nouvelle
zac et aux alentours
je j'entends les craintes d'impact que
ça peut avoir à travailler dessus y'a
pas il n'y a pas de nom solution au
problème
la nouvelle évolution du programme
urbain entraîne une reprise des études
du projet celui ci devrait permettre
d'établir une part de logements sociaux
à hauteur de 25%
aucun calendrier en revanche n'est
encore fixée pour le début des travaux